if you want to be in the club then you
have to wear a bra
oh
do you you think you need one
hello Margaret we're here too and with
some great picks for this week to go
along with the book adaptation minus all
that pesky page turning we're also
serving up a World War II action flick a
couple of secret spies with lots of star
power a movie combining martial arts and
sisterly love and the return of the top
ranked show about a half human half deer
you heard that right Rotten Tomatoes is
steering your antlers in the right
direction on this week's what to watch
do this one thing for me
[Music]
something just be normal and regular
like everybody else just please please
please please please please please
please please
turn in the page right into theaters is
are you there God it's me Margaret this
coming-of-age dramedy is of course based
on the 1970 Judy Bloom novel of the same
name it stars Abby writer forston as 11
year old Margaret along with Rachel
McAdams as her mother and Kathy Bates as
her grandmother and yeah that would be
amazing to have those two as your mom
and grandma the film was written for the
screen and directed by Kelly Freeman
Craig who teamed up with legendary
producer James L Brooks for this project
after previously working together on the
Edge of Seventeen so in other words this
adaptation is in great hands early
reviews have this one very fresh on the
Tomato Meter with a score of 99 and an
audience score hovering around 100 those
bookworms love their adaptations I
really believe that he's immortal no he
just refuses to die how many Minds did
you bury here all of them
also opening in theaters is the
historical action Flix sisu besides just
being fun to say one reason to give this
film a look is the unique premise it's
set in Northern Finland during World War
II and follows a gold prospector trying
to protect his stash from a Nazi death
squad and with popular Finnish filmmaker
yalmari halander at the helm sisu
debuted at the Toronto International
Film Festival last fall and made an
impact on critics with a strong showing
on the Tomato Meter so far and don't
just take our word for it top critic
Megan Navarro from Bloody Disgusting
said that this movie feels like a gritty
actioner of yesteryear but with a modern
sense of style I wish someone would
describe me that way and there's no one
else it's just you and me
oh
everything you know
you know is a lie
premiering on Amazon Prime video is the
mystery thriller series Citadel now the
first reason to check out this show is a
two-parter Richard Madden and Priyanka
Chopra Jonas I know right they play a
couple of elite spies who are
reactivated to pretty much save the
world as Elite spies tend to do shout
out to all my spy friends that I may or
may not have another strong Resume
Builder for Citadel is that it was
created by David wheel who also did the
Amazon show hunters and it was produced
by Brothers Joe and Anthony Russo of
Marvel Fame plus season 2 has already
gotten the green light so it's okay to
fully commit to this one I know that can
be hard for some of you and while you're
watching it's cool to know that this
series will include spin-offs in
different languages and set in different
countries they're going global baby I
found something
they are not taking her away without a
fight
finding its manners on its way into
theaters is the action comedy polite
Society this film focuses on two British
Pakistani sisters one is a martial
artist in training who tries to save the
other from her impending marriage by way
of an ambitious wedding Heist Gotta Love
sisters it was written and directed by
Anita manzoor in her feature film
directorial debut after turning heads
with the award-winning British sitcom we
are lady Parts polite Society is
certified fresh at 93 on the Tomato
Meter after premiering at the Sundance
Film Festival earlier this year with
critics using words like fresh and a
delight to describe it so you know It's
gotta be good just a matter of time
before the whole world learns
drivers
and when that happens everyone will want
a pizza to you
and thankfully having Zero Effect on
your dentist bill this month is the
return of the series Sweet Tooth okay
couple great things about this show for
one it's based on a comic book of the
same name by Jeff Lemire and it's about
a half boy half deer living an
apocalyptic world
um yes please critics were definitely
feeling the certified fresh first season
which is at 97 on the Tomato Meter and
the critics consensus calls it
emotionally engaging superbly acted and
Incredibly entertaining wow all that and
it has human slash animal hybrids and to
make this an Iron Man I mean Ironclad
case let's not forget that Robert Downey
Jr and his wife Susan Downey are among
the show's executive producers nothing
like a little behind the scenes
Firepower
there you go another great list of what
to watch this week and the cool thing is
while it does have something for
everybody you'll love it all says a lot
about you and be sure to let us all know
in the comments what you did check out
whether it was on this list or not
remember to check out rottentomatoes.com
for the latest updates on scores and
reviews for everything mentioned as well
as the movie and TV World At Large and
don't forget to stop by the new rt25
page where we're celebrating 25 years of
rotten tomatoes and while you're there
you'll probably notice that we have a
brand new card game putting your mind to
the test on 25 years of Tomato Meter
scores get five now you'll have b-day
gifts for the rest of the year and one
for yourself you're welcome that's all
for today fresh family until next week
stay fresh
all right